[Music]
well if it isn't the reject nation i'm
greg alba i'm kyla ryng kyle element
from the fan theory youtube channel is
here with me today we watched the movie
together it called happy deathday we
actually went to the cgv cinemas and one
apart
they invited us to come along we shot a
vlog over there they're doing like a
haunted sort of Halloween experience
over there where they have like a whole
bunch of costumes clown zombies zombies
a bunch of decoration some spooky noises
here there it allowed us to test out
that a 40x experience so big thank you
to see GV cinemas for letting us attend
your theater and document our experience
going there and they also let us watch
happy deathday there we really didn't
want to go out a way to say thank you to
you guys for letting us at least a 10
year theater and please check out our
vlog colin i we shot a lot so please go
check it out jab eco is if you guys are
familiar with m2 but all it's a happy
death day it's about a girl in college
who is one of them Legally Blonde - yeah
over-exaggerated he's a valley girl
blonde she gets killed but she keeps
repeating the same day over and over
again think edge of tomorrow think
Groundhog Day when you see the trailer
you're like oh it's like screaming it's
Groundhog Day yeah it is yeah I think
it's really enjoyable I don't think it's
a great movie by any stretch it feels
weird to even qualify in the horror
genre cuz it's just it's more just kind
of a story arc where something has to be
revealed there's like some horror stuff
in it there's some suds a little bit of
sci-fi especially of its concept that
it's dealing with it's an interesting
mix on the slasher genre because I was
still considered as a slasher film yeah
absolutely but it's not exactly scary
and it's not exactly hilarious it's not
really even that gory either
no no they actually know something I
kind of wish they didn't skimp out on
which is like let's see some of the
violence when she gets killed you know
and I was kind of expecting that since
it's from the people behind the purge in
all those movies yeah it's from Blum
House yeah yeah I was expecting
something a little more gory and graphic
and I was like oh alright well this is
fun I wasn't on the edge
I mean it was just more like ah yeah
yeah yeah the movies the movies fun I
wouldn't say I was ever bored I think it
kind of goes on a little too long got to
a point where you're like this is kind
of stretching itself out a little bit
you know I think the big strength of
this film is the actress the the lead
actress in the film Jessica Roth ro th
or wrote some yeah she's the main
character in this film and there are
some scenes where she's like a little
over the top but then I kind of saw it
as a character choice because you see
over the course of the film that this is
sort of a persona she's been put and she
evolves over time through them yeah yeah
which is great cuz that she gets more
vulnerable as you start peeling back the
layers to see why she is the way she is
and maybe why the world has put her on
this specific experience of a Groundhog
Day type of thing she has some pretty
powerful scenes and there's some there's
some great moments with her where you're
like this is she's a great actress and
there's a lot of scenes where you're
like she does a really really good job
one scene that surprised me were I was
kind of moved to like a little
misty-eyed at one point I know we're
talking about yeah I got a little misty
eye because of her performance and she
has some really laugh-out-loud moments
to she carries this whole film every
every scenes over every single every
single scene yeah this isn't like a
typical like slasher we're like they're
going around and like your victim number
one your Vic yeah - I mean there's
victims along the way sort of but she's
really just the victim of this movie
yeah yeah I would say there's some
pretty pretty cool editing tricks that
go on in this movie there's some awesome
cinematography that happens a director
like to play a lot with the types of
lens he likes to use depending on the
state she's in that's something I
appreciate about this because it's one
of those movies where she keeps
repeating the same day over and over
again it takes a toll on her as time
goes on some day she's embracing it some
day she's just sick of it and whatever
I'm just gonna go about it some day
she's mad about it you know it felt like
it started off as like a [ __ ] House
Bunny that converted into sort of like a
real human I think the movie gets better
over the course of it yeah
you're watching it it gets little like
alright we get it already but it is a
little long for what it is
but I still think that the movie grows
on you as you watch it one thing that
was kind of slightly frustrating to me
about it is I don't know if there's a
word for this the concept of character
who relives the same day over and over
again there's a pretty obvious beat
structure especially after watching this
specific film yeah and it's been done in
TV - a few times yeah we get it we get
it
they go through the same day on the
second day is like whoa deja vu third
day I think I'm going crazy
fourth day they tell someone fifth day
they start going they start embracing it
and going insane and they get we get a
montage of them repeating repeating
repeating then it starts to get darker
you know it's like this very similar
process in and all of these movies and I
felt like this didn't really break that
until towards the end when there was a
surprise when you think the movies
wrapping up oh yeah yeah sort of a
surprise twist in its execution yeah
where you're like huh but it keeps going
so towards the end it's starting to
break away from typical structure had
some nice twist to it I really think the
strength of this film is on Jessica Ross
performance and the the cinematography
is really good I just wish that it can
be a little stronger in its genre that
it's categorized in it could have gone a
lot edgier than it did I always expect
like initially when the movie started
and there was the first violent act I
was like flinch and then was like wait
wait wait I was like oh alright yeah I
thought they could have had fun with its
violence and gore when really there's
barely any violence in this film and is
this film radars I could tell because it
didn't feel like rated R to me so it is
pg-13 oh it is pg-13 teresting it can
get away with me in pg-13 they could
have easily made it rain in our movie
yeah I made a few tweaks I thought that
this movie could have been a little bit
more special if it was rated R yeah as
much as like it's not completely
necessary I'm like what it is a slasher
film and I thought you could have had a
little fun with the gore you know she's
gonna survive it cos you know she's
gonna wake up again like you could have
had fun doing that cuz I'm like edge of
tomorrow's pg-13
keeps dying all the time but even edge
of tomorrow has a gory death the first
time he dies he's all burnt up that's
like oh but there's you never get that
in a horror slasher movie with this
concept yeah you're never like oh and I
think that would soften the blow for
anyone who was squeamish - gory movies
that's the one thing I would say I'm
kind of sad that they didn't act yeah or
pray more because it's the perfect
environment yeah there's some fun Gore
yeah it doesn't have to be like scary
gore but it could be like fun Gore cuz
you know she's just gonna wake up the
next day it won't be like this is just
like yeah alright cool she wakes up
we're cool oh yeah it would intensify
the situation and it'll and without
giving anything away I don't even know
if the trailer gave it away there is an
interesting residual effect that goes on
with her as this process of her dying
keeps going that other movies haven't
done which I appreciate there's a couple
of new things they tweak with this
premise that we've seen before
yeah but in terms of its structure of
how it plays out it's very familiar and
predictable and how it plays out and the
film is just overall enjoyable it's fun
it doesn't quite reach the heights at
which you're like it could have but it's
all there but it doesn't quite go to the
length work you're like it could have
gone there but I did it and I thought by
the end of the movie shed a really good
character arc oh no she completely grew
yeah yeah and it was a it was a it was
done in a way where I I felt it I felt
the art there's something that they
could have easily just put on paper and
then been like yep okay thanks for
telling me her art but it was something
that I did feel and that's what moved me
into being a little misty-eyed if I were
you were like a star rating I would
probably give it like a like a 3 out of
5 I think that's a fair yeah because it
was it was still an enjoyable movie it
was fun to watch I mean the story was
engaging enough it just didn't go far
yeah anyway guys did you see happy
deathday did you love it did you hate it
did you cry did you laugh how do you
feel about your life well you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click got notification bell kyle i
Lerman is a part of the fan theory
channel he is not part he is the fan
theory channel go check it out it's a
fantastic channel my friends go check
out our patreon become a patron object
today and please go ahead and check out
our vlog that we did
Kyle and I did together over at cgb
cinemas once again they're an awesome
cinema down in Buena Park and they had
this whole haunted theater experience
going on that's fantastic I'm gonna be
going back myself for the next two
weekends with John some guys live in
Buena Park and you want to come say hi
to me go for it I will be there gonna
watch Leatherface there next weekend and
the weekend after that jigsaw so go
ahead and say hi to me let me know
huit me Instagram me if you want to
catch up